You know as a parent – so I have an 11 year
old and a 7 year old and I’ve gone through
the whole process up until now.
I think I have like I would say like a ten
year market study of my kids’ eating habits
and how they were formed and hopefully like
where I can take them to.
When they were young and I’m going to go
back all the way to like from bottle feeding.
They went from breast milk to formula and
then onto solid foods.
And that was a key point where we could still
control what they were having, what their
intake was.
And knowing this as a chef I would make fresh
purees in the restaurants and then cryovac
them.
So I would make sweet potato puree, malanga
puree, spinach and carrot.
These days you can vacuum seal just about
anything.
You can buy a vacuum seal at Target and make
your purees, put them in the freezer, pull
them out and then, you know, you’re giving
– you can really at that point still control
their internal environment.
I think where we made a mistake – and I’ll
say this is that we started to – as they
got older we started introducing them to whether
it was pastas or French fries and that sort
of kind of like, you know, the busy parent
ends up feeling like oh, I just want to like
feed them and move on.
And it’s foods that they like and I just
think that that’s a mistake that we made
and now ever since then we’re still trying
to make up the ground on how do we get kids
away from these unhealthy foods that they
naturally gravitate towards.
I think that there’s a textural issue with
kids that really is hard to overcome.
So I’ve kind of overcome that by doing a
lot of, putting a lot of things in the blender
and getting that first initial eating experience
as a soup.
So it’s a warm soup but that has all the
good nutritional ingredients and elements
into it so that they can have something healthy.
And then at that point it’s still a battle,
it’s still tough.